so um today we're asking people the
question people in london so since women
have the right to choose right we have
the right to get an abortion for free in
london up to six months
should men have the right to a financial
abortion where they can sign off their
rights and they don't have to pay child
support i believe that's yes i believe a
yes to that and i believe
but you you need to figure out like a
tighter
schedule for how it should work like
okay um if you're not married like if
you're gonna have the baby you need the
guy to sign off
before a certain time that he's gonna
accept all the financial
responsibilities for it
and then make it binding and i think
you'd have to kind of have a real set
structure to it
i don't think if you like
he goes yes yes yes and he goes actually
you know what
i've said yes and i'm going to change my
mind i don't think it should be like
that
but i think you should definitely like
have to sign something prior to prior to
the birth
why
why do you think we have child support
because why because in my head it's like
why
are i as a woman entitled to a man's
money
it's all based on
i personally think it's a lot of it's
based around
the perception of
it's quite sexist and the perception of
the woman is the weaker sex
the woman is not as able to earn as much
that the woman's always manipulated into
a situation of having a child
so
it's their sort of
support on that level i mean when you
get to it
it's kind of um yeah it's kind of a bit
unbalanced
i agree i agree i think it's very
unbalanced do you um so do you think
abortion should be legal at all yeah i
think
i think it should be i think it should
be i mean
i can always say as a guy on some level
i have benefited from it
in different ways on certain levels
whether it being
someone
when i was much much younger you know
someone got pregnant and i think it's
wow if i think back now if that person
had a child i'd have been tied to them
for 18 plus years it wouldn't have
worked out well for me um
so i i think it should be legal but i
definitely think they should now as i'm
getting older i'm realizing there should
be a lot more education about it a
little bit more about some of the facts
of it but i definitely think it should
be always a choice
when do you think abortion should be
legal up to to be honest as a guy i i
just don't know
i've not got like a set like
right it should there's this particular
date my timeline for it i'm you know i'm
not i don't i'm on a woman's woman's
personal choice i don't get that
involved i mean obviously when it's like
to the point of like nine months i'm
gonna say oh yeah week before yeah just
whip it out and get rid of it but you
know it's legal in the uk up to six
months
yes you just told me yeah you just told
me i mean to be honest
it was never really in my mind like
my level of awareness of when when the
deadline was i think i remember it got
extended maybe
10 15 years ago got lengthened out but
yeah and did you know the earliest child
to survive a pregnancy is 21 weeks
and uh so and right now it's legal up to
24.
i did not know that
i didn't know that no and did you know
that 40 of women that have had abortions
um or 40 of women getting an abortion
have had two or more abortions in the
past
once again another another statistic i
did i didn't know i'm just curious if
that like changes your opinion on it at
all unlike when it should be legal it
doesn't really change my opinion
but i i definitely feel that both sides
should be have been allowed to um
voice their concerns
i'm not like
if someone feels it should be illegal
they should be shouted down
i can i can see where a lot of people
are coming from i mean
the whole concept of like birth control
and abortion has definitely changed the
dynamics between men and women and well
it gives all the power to women right
yeah on a reproductive level i mean
yes it is there's a lot of
responsibility but it can't well a lot
of power but it comes without the shame
and a lot of the issues of the past
because there's always a potential for
women to become pregnant and have a baby
but you know if you went back
60 60 plus years ago there's a huge
aspect of the shame and social con
social conventions
and everything else i think i think it's
what people expect
of a single memory single motherhood is
a little bit skewed from what i've seen
now from what i've seen women go through
well it seems like it's almost
incentivized to be a single mother
because you get money for it you get
money for it either through child
support or from the government
yeah
so it's like if you incentivize
something more people are going to do it
oh yeah for for sure i mean
there's always the trope of
if a single mother be able to get more
easily get like um flat from the council
from housing or in america it was like
if in the housing projects it was is
much easier but now it's gone from being
that just a perception of easier to
it's been rebranded to the strong
independent single mother
um i mean i personally think that
raising a child is a team sport i mean
you know ideally you need you need both
parents actively participating to have a
full well-rounded child what laws would
you see like what laws would you like to
see in the future that would advocate
for men i'd like to see compulsory dna
tests
um
because just
there seems to be a lot
not a lot i don't know the active
statistics but i think that would help
to clear up situations where you know
someone's getting pregnant and then they
think you know what the guy i was
sexually attracted to and i've actually
become pregnant to is not as stable as
candidate number candidate b
who i can say hey we've had a baby and
i can sort of tie down because you hear
these stories and it's you know it gets
scary so there's that i think the
contractual situation be much clearer i
think because then
you can guarantee a certain level of
rights because i've heard so many
stories from real friends
where
the relationship was going well at the
start things have broken down
then maybe they've not got married they
have no real parental rights over the
child so if there was like the
whole
agreement situation beforehand then
there'd be an agreement already
regarding um
visitation or
just parental rights well i've heard i
have a friend named sarah and he
advocates for marriage contracts
that go for a certain amount of time and
you can renegotiate
yeah i mean i do remember as a my
friend's
sister's husband said oh you know
marriage is like a business and i think
it was more like different people in the
partnership take different roles
but i can see how that could i could see
how that could work but then also as
well then it's like
it makes it quite cold the whole aspect
of it being a contract but then i could
see the logic behind it the logic is
strong
do you think the more our society has
focused on loved as opposed to duty that
marriage has broken down because of that
yeah because it's
well yeah i mean
i guess i mean my parents are like well
my my dad's past my mum's 76 and you
hear the story a lot of it's duty like
making things work they eventually they
got divorced and then they came back
together
but i think a lot of people's versions
of love is more lust
or infatuation and it's gonna pass
there's not a case of right we've been
brought together we've got we built
something together let's make this last
it's like oh i'm tired of you now i'm
fed up with this
let's keep it moving but you've got now
you've brought kids into the world it's
due love is overtaken duty by a long
shot i think disney has played a lot
into it because people think it's like
supposed to be this electric like fairy
tale sort of thing
yeah i mean i can't i can't i can't
speak for obviously i can't speak for
women yeah of course but you know
for guys i think because obviously not
obviously i thought guys are more logic
based quite often
and they're kind of a bit more pragmatic
whereas you know we're talking to lots
of different women over time it does
feel they're looking for that spark and
then you're like look you're talking
about you're on a family you're looking
for a spark but
you're 39.
well
you know i mean i mean you know i don't
want to be horrible i mean there's
there's the chance she loves a young
person's game
i think like love and not being loving
is a human condition but the whole but
living in that realm of possibility it
it's more practical it's easier when
you're younger
actually i think it's to be to be really
fair when i was younger i didn't have
any idea understanding of it i think now
it's much it's much easier for a guy on
certain levels
because you have more time because for a
woman it's when you know when i was 21
and the girl was like really hustling me
like what do you want to do where you
were going i think i would be young like
relax because now i can look back at it
and go [ __ ] she had a point because for
her her window her time her window time
is very very short i mean ninety percent
of our eggs are gone by 30. yeah i heard
that i've had that conversation with
a girl she was like 32-33
and she got it but you know as a guy
most girls don't really want to have
that conversation yeah you know women
leave 70 to 80 of the time in marriages
and 90 if they're college educated so
it's really not the men that are
breaking up the home it's the women yeah
i kind of knew that already and i'd seen
it already i mean because i used to work
quite a lot for in the nightlife
industry so i've
people i've known for like over years
and years i've seen their patterns and
it does make me question because there's
not many guys who like yeah jumping up
and down wanting like i really need to
get married and have this romantic
wedding and everything else i've always
what i've always thought about and then
they concede and they do it because they
feel that that's what they need to
access this girl and give her what she
wants and then she gets bored
it or all the guys are stuck in
situations where
it's just barren because the the
attraction's gone yeah
well thank you so much for
for sitting down um you're kind of red
pill i don't know if you you watch red
pill content yes love it love it
um bits and pieces i mean it's
i think to be honest some of it is just
it's just like what was never really
allowed to be said if you're if you've
got some experience
but you know
i always kind of um
look to still maintain some compassion
well thank you very much appreciate it